there's a woman at a colorado school
board meeting
a local radio host and a a mom
in this this district actually a member
of the concerned parent
organization parents united america and
she just spoke out at the douglas county
school district
against this issue that's becoming
increasingly prominent
and it's you know from the way you know
ethereal realm of the ivory tower the
but it's it's really now having
a practical effect on kids education and
on our political life
she spoke out against critical race
theory when we look at the gemini group
teaching
which i took time to watch the entire
thing
it is even more disturbing and this
group was hired
by this board because in that training
it talks about oppressors and oppressed
that is damaging to every group of
children first of all
some group of children are thought of as
being shamed for who they are the others
are taught that they are victims
without the ability to further
themselves and to look at the others as
the enemies
we all know the the dr king quote that
has been shared
color of our skin versus the content of
our character he had a dream
this is a nightmare it is a nightmare
for our children and it needs to end now
the training also by the way divides
basically
educators and parents because in the
training it refers to parents as
dissenters we are not dissenters we
are the parents it goes on to say and
train educators
to tell dissenters that this is simply
the way we are going to educate
your children they are our children
we are the ones that have the moral
authority over their education
will not be marginalized of course but
they are being marginalized i mean she
makes an excellent point here but that
that is what's happening this is not
just some kooky theory that was
developed
in the front for school 100 years ago or
rather a derivation of these
of critical theory more broadly that was
developed by the frankfurt school which
by the way i discussed in my opinion
books speeches controlling words
controlling minds which is available now
for pre-order wherever you get your fine
books
but this is having a practical effect
because you're not just reading a book
and having an academic discussion
that's never what these theories were
about this is about practical training
to get power to establish a racial caste
system in america
which is what's being done and it's
being done and drilled into the minds of
five-year-olds and people who are even
younger than that
and it's being drilled into people's
minds in the workplace and it's being
drilled into people's minds in the
government institutions
it's even being drilled into people's
minds in the military
you've got to fight back against that or
you're going to look up and realize that
your culture
is completely been inverted things
happen gradually and then suddenly and
we're in the suddenly part of that
these people are telling you what what
they believe you can read the training
materials
you can you can read the the writings of
these critical theorists
you can read the emails of dr fauci for
goodness sakes you can see
where they're saying yes we're making
political decisions here because we
think this is the kind of society we
should have
not on making a scientific observation
these are the facts no
even think of the 1619 project we're not
saying this is the new fact and here's
the old no 1619 project
is based on a lie the central lie that
the american revolution was fought to
preserve slavery there's just no
evidence of that whatsoever it's bogus
but what the 1619 project tries to do is
reframe american history what dr fauci
is doing in his public position
is deciding between what he thinks is
better and worse for society as a
political matter
not what is true and false as a
scientific matter but what he thinks is
what people should do and should not do
is a question of
morality that's what the critical
theorists are doing it's what all
education is doing
and the republicans and the
conservatives have thrown up their hands
and said oh well
you know you do you it's all freedom we
can never use political power well
look what happens as a result of that
there is one hope for conservatives
in this crazy culture we're looking and
we're
i mean how many times do we need to say
we were right we were right we were
right
and all the authorities and all the
institutions were wrong and they were
wrong and they were wrong it doesn't
matter
we can we can say we were right until we
were blue in the face they're the ones
with the political power
right they're still able to do it they
lied in many ways about the reasons for
the lockdown they lied about the
efficacy of masks they lied about
the risk of asymptomatic spread they
lied about the risk to young people they
lie they lie they lie they lie they lie
and it doesn't matter they keep getting
away with it
why because they have the political
power and they're willing to use it and
we don't
there's one bit of hope for now to fight
back which is
they don't quite have the common sense
they don't they don't and this is
something that
antonio gramsci one of the founders of
this school of radicalism
who i'm not even going to mention what
book
he has discussed at great length in
because i don't want to break my cameras
again on this show but i think look i
think we all know what we're talking
about
antonio gramsci pointed out that
radical revolutions fail because the
kooky crazy leftist theorists
don't have a grasp on the common sense
that the common people the proletariat
the workers of the world
actually it turns out they like their
traditions and their way of life in
their communities
more than they like the radicals insane
theories so the trick is you've got to
take over the common sense
oh hey you nice to see you i wish i
could
see you more often i wish i could see
you more
reliably and the way that i can do that
is if you ring that bell ring that bell
subscribe like that way you will be able
to get the notifications
head on over to apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher
myspace xanga aol instant messenger
subscribe
to the audio podcast the michael nelson
leave a five-star review we'd really
appreciate it
i'll see you next time and i'll miss you
until then
[Music]
[Music]
you